getting excited all about the Super Bowl
yet has it happened anybody here excited
about this Wow
late I'll see what's weird this we live
in Los Angeles are you even aware LA is
in the Superbowl anybody that's pathetic
here's a where's a weird truth if you
know there's a football team in LA
chances are you're probably playing on
it it is really freaking cold in the
Midwest it is so cold
truck nuts on the back of pickups have
moved up inside the truck
[Applause]
that's our next format the one joke
format always about testicles yeah yeah
no it's it's really this weather is
messing up everything Amtrak is
canceling services in some areas yeah in
other words Amtrak is not affected thank
you three people but the polar vortex
that's what they call I love that name
the polar vortex yeah polar vortex will
soon leave the Midwest and move into New
York yes there it will share an
apartment with six other vortexes we'll
get an apartment
one of them's named Joey I can keep
going a long time I'm gonna keep coming
it'll run for 11 seasons when they get
in aw you're just odd for no reason it
doesn't make sense to all at that this
is interesting to save energy people in
Minnesota asked not to heat homes have
been asked not to heat their homes above
60 degrees yeah yeah people in Minnesota
replied you
[Applause]